junge menschen ohne stimme asylbewerber
doch nur ii und hussein sind eine
absolute ausnahme unter den rund 130.000
asylsuchenden in deutschland sie reisen
durch die republik stehen mit der band
the fugees auf der bühne und rappen vom
trostlosen alltag als flüchtlingskinder
nuri aus der russischen teilrepublik
dagestan ist anfang 20 sein halbes leben
hatte in einem norddeutschen
asylbewerberheim verbracht bis vor
kurzem in einem zimmer mit eltern und
schwester
weiter verbessert
berlin
natürlich mag ich wieder über 22
weiter
in dagestan einer unruhe region im
kaukasus fühlte sich nuris familie nicht
mehr sicher als asylgrund zählt das hier
nicht ständig ist der von abschiebung
bedroht ein leben in angst dass vielen
deutschen unbekannt ist es gab auch
welche die zu unseren konzerten gekommen
sind und gesagt haben ja früher ich
wusste gar nichts von der sache aber
wenn ich gerade von euch gehört habe und
von den songs und dieser messe wo wir an
die leute weitergegeben haben mit der
musik halten die das ist einfach so
krass obwohl die obwohl die leute auch
früher gar nicht wussten was wir ein
problem ist in deutschland er hatte die
idee mit flüchtlingen eine band zu
gründen der deutsche liedermacher heinz
ratz deutschland aus seiner sicht kein
schönes land für flüchtlinge das erlebte
er mit seiner band strom und wasser auf
benefiz tour durch asylbewerberheim
ich habe 2011 habe ich ungefähr 80
flüchtlingsheime besucht
und hab da
war da total in sich von dem was ich da
vorgefunden habe es hat mir auch sehr
traurig gemacht und ich konnte hat mich
nicht in ruhe gelassen und da habe ich
mir überlegt was ich nehme noch schönes
altes mehr hervorheben kann mir viel ein
wie viele tolle musiker dort vor sich
hin vegetieren ohne die chance ihre
lieder zu spielen und daraufhin habe ich
sie nach hamburg eingeladen haben eine
cd mit ihnen aufgenommen und bin jetzt
ob tun
so hatte auch nuri und hussein
kennengelernt
für sie ist durch das refugees projekt
ein traum wahr geworden
auf einmal ist da interesse für ihre
geschichte der 18-jährige hossein floh
aus dem iran weil er dort kein rapper
sein dürfte ich hab so viele stars auch
mit meinem vater er hat hier ist ein
muslimisches land und macht musik von
also musik der ungläubigen schon
husseins eltern flohen aus afghanistan
in den iran
doch im land der mullahs ist ein leben
als hip-hopper gefährlich ein islam
kritisches lied wurde dem damals 15
jährigen zum verhängnis hilfe aber vom
kinder- und danach einen tag habe ich
hab dann die flucht zwei jahre brauchte
hossein um nach deutschland zu gelangen
da seine hoffnung auf eine glückliche
zukunft hat auf diesem harten und
gefährlichen weg nie verloren
deutschland haben die beiden dank des
projekts inzwischen recht gut
kennengelernt
an jedem auftrittsort besuchen sie ein
asylbewerberheim dass die musiker reisen
dürfen das geht nur mit
sondergenehmigungen normalerweise dürfen
sich asylbewerber in deutschland nicht
frei bewegen den landkreis oder das
bundesland nicht verlassen
residenzpflicht heißt dass auch hier in
rostock lagen sie flüchtlinge zu ihrem
konzert ein gratis versteht sich eine
willkommene abwechslung im monotonen
alltag der asylbewerber
die konzerte von strom und wasser
featuring the fugees eine der wenigen
gelegenheiten von asylbewerbern auch mit
deutschen in kontakt zu kommen
inzwischen gibt es auch von der politik
anerkennung bandleader heinz ratz wurde
für das projekt die integrations
medaille der bundesrepublik deutschland
verliehen
nun gewisser schutz ist vielleicht auch
diese medaille weil die bundesregierung
her immerhin das projekt dadurch
offiziell gemacht hat und schlecht ja
mich auszeichnen kann und die
involvierten flüchtlinge gleichzeitig
abschieben kann und das ist leuchten
werden auch klar eine garantie dass sie
bleiben können ist das jedoch nicht
trotzdem auf der bühne zu stehen macht
sie glücklich aber manche träume und
wünsche bleiben
ich habe einfach nicht gesehen
eine zweite sache
ich glaube geht nicht aber wir versuchen
eine welt ohne grenzen rassist
hier gibt es diese welt schon
flüchtlinge und deutsche zusammen im
publikum und auf der bühne
die anerkennung der klaus dank des
projekts ist ihr leben in deutschland
ein wenig weniger sinnlos geworden